[Music]
[Applause]
Bob Costas uh he was handling
play-by-play duties alongside Ron
Darling for the Yankees game Yankees
Guardians on TBS game two tomorrow night
in the Bronx Bob also has HBO's back on
the record with Bob Costas and works for
MLB Network Bob joining us now Bob how
did it feel last night
it felt great it was a beautiful night
at the Ballpark there was a tremendous
atmosphere even though the Yankees would
appear to be kind of in a Goliath versus
David situation and despite the fact
that the Guardians didn't do much on
offense last night they're a much
different team over the last six weeks
or so than they were during the course
of the season and with Terry Francona at
the helm they've always got a chance so
I think it's an interesting an
interesting matchup
meanwhile I will say this with certainty
neither I nor Jerry Jones will be the
most noteworthy caller you have spoken
with to speak with this morning
um I'm sorry that we had to bring you
down to our Debs of degradation here Bob
you know they say you should never you
should never follow kids
and there's a there's a third part of
that uh of that Trifecta now
uh man and and you know we had a caller
yesterday saying that he knew a woman
whose first name was Jenna and last name
was toles and uh so it it took a little
while for fritzy to to get it so this is
how it sounded yesterday
I didn't catch the last name he said
genitals I I didn't I think we got it I
guess you did catch it
okay
so so that was yesterday Bob and then
you have this so this guy you know Dan
what we're we're a relatively Advanced
ages but there's still a call back to
those adolescent times remember when
they used to pass around an attendance
sheet when you had a substitute teacher
yeah and then there would be three or
four names that you'd write down on the
attendance sheet or at least the class
clown in the back of the room would
hoping that the hapless substitute
teacher would then call out that
person's name and the corresponding
response would convulse every boy in the
room and repulse every girl in the room
uh Ben Dover yeah yeah that's mild yes
but bend over is part of it yes did you
ever get in trouble in like real trouble
in school
in high schools 1968 early 1969 and I
lived down the street from an elementary
school and we used to go shoot baskets
you know on the playground of the
elementary school or toss baseballs
around in the in the schoolyard so we
use that as kind of our playground the
kids that were roughly my age and one
Friday afternoon not me but one of our
group went into the school to get a
drink of water from the fountain and the
gym teacher's door was open remember how
every teacher especially the gym teacher
had a ring of keys that had like 50 keys
on it you wonder what the heck it was
one of them must be to Fort Knox or
something so this kid whose name was
Jerry I will not further identify him
steals the the Ring of keys takes us hey
look what I've got now some in the group
had nefarious ideas my idea was wait a
minute wait a minute we'll keep the keys
they'll replace them but what we'll do
is we'll go into the gym on the weekends
it's winter time we don't want to shoot
baskets in the snow we'll go and we'll
play in the gym and we'll have our own
little league but we got to keep it a
secret so this went on for like five six
weeks every Saturday Sunday we're
playing in the school gym seems really
cool you know we're playing full court
shirts and skins the whole deal but
eventually apparently word got around
and one Sunday afternoon I look up and
walking down the hallway is a uniformed
policeman and they go to round us up and
everybody Sprints out the door there's
only like eight of us because we tried
to keep it a tight group everybody
Sprints out the door and tries to escape
I somehow managed to escape and I lived
only you know a block or two from the
elementary school so I get home and I
think I'm safe until two squad cars pull
up Commack Long Island was not a high
crime area so really this this whole
drag that could focus on these
miscreants playing basketball in the
elementary school gym and the next thing
you know I'm being walk out of my house
by two cops and the neighbors are out on
the stoop what could Bobby Costas have
done a fairly benign looking 16 year old
they take us down all eight of us and
they actually book us and the cops are
laughing like hey look at this kid here
he's a regular Bob Cousy this guy's
Marcus Haynes so now we have to go to
court right and when the judge sees what
it is and he's got other cases there
he's got grand larceny and everything
the judge sees what it is and he says
this is really terrible it's a real
crime wave blah blah blah he's mocking
the fact that we're in court and he
dismisses the charges but we were
suspended from school and our parents
had to come down and testify that we
would never misbehave to this level
again and never never follow a life of
crime so that was the one time that I
that I got in trouble I was suspended
for a week yeah so it's like those kids
who meet the inmates and scared straight
like so you you never went down that
path again
that's right that's right and we're all
better for them
um I uh I mentioned this in the first
hour with Bryce Harper
um you know he's been on the stage since
he was what 16 when he was on the cover
sport it's Illustrated and he's had two
MVPs he's won two World Series titles
and I said I think he's going to be a
Hall of Famer now I I it's a dangerous
game to play when you go he's not even
30 yet but it feels like he's going to
be a Hall of Famer where do you stand
with Bryce Harper where he is right now
yeah he's got time to build on his
resume but it's pointed in that
direction and there's so many different
ways you can interpret what a Hall of
Famer is Roger Maris won two MVPs back
to back played on seven pennant winners
and what happened with judge this year
proves yet again how Roger maris's name
resonates throughout baseball history
he's a more significant historic figure
than most of the players in the Hall of
Fame not necessarily a better player but
you can make a case for him you can make
a really good case for Keith Hernandez
or Steve Garvey whose power numbers
don't match up with what we expect of a
first baseman these days but in the
context of their time they were more
impactful than a lot of guys whose Ops
may be higher in the context of the 21st
century Dale Murphy won back-to-back
MVPs and for a while was regarded as one
of the two or three best players in the
game as was Don Mattingly Dave Parker
was a better player than a lot of guys
who were in the Hall of Fame so a lot of
it depends upon how the voters are
interpreting it if they're going
strictly on the basis of analytics
what's this guy's war or whatever then
perhaps it's more cut and dry but some
people view it as I do as a combination
of what the statistics are and some
subjective but at least informed
understanding of what their place in
history was and what their impact was
against their contemporaries we're
talking to Bob Costas he'll be with Ron
Darling and the ALDS between the
Guardians and Yankees on TBS game two
tomorrow night in the Bronx at 7 30
Eastern are we past the anti-astro
sentiment
now I think some of the lingers uh if
they were to meet the Dodgers for
example in the World Series uh the
Dodger fan base still feels as if uh
they were they were jobbed in 2017 in
the World Series so I think they would
hear it uh a lot of Yankee fans still
resent the Astros and they could be on a
collision course in the LCS so you could
have two prime examples LCS against the
Yankees and possibly World Series
against the Dodgers I think it's calmed
down overall but it hasn't disappeared
and in some places the fires still rage
what's the one piece of sports
memorabilia that you wish you would have
held on to or you had the opportunity to
get
this once before Dad and I've never
really been a collector and I never
really wanted to impose on people but I
was lucky enough because of my
connection to baseball to interview and
in some cases become friends with the
real bold face names of our childhood
maze Aaron mantle even before my
childhood DiMaggio Williams and I never
really asked them for much of anything I
have a few signed baseballs which I gave
to my son Keith who now works for the
baseball Network and was a real baseball
fan even as a little kid so I've got
signed baseballs from all the guys I
just mentioned and a few others but I
didn't really go out of my way to get
anything else and I never really looked
at it as having any other value except
sentimental never any commercial value
because I talked to Doc emmerich and Doc
would keep all of his boards you know
when he would do a play-by-play all of
his notes and and I was curious do you
keep all of your uh you know scorecards
or boards that you have for the games
that you've done yeah I keep them for a
while uh if it's still relevant two
years three years later if there are
notes on players that are still involved
and then after that I get rid of them
except I keep the ones that are most
significant I keep the ones from like
the seventh game of the World Series I
kept the one from Steven strasberg's
debut when he struck out 14 for the
Nationals and he was briefly uh
sensation around baseball moments like
that Derek Jeter's last game at Yankee
Stadium uh moments like that I've kept
the scorecards could the Dodgers be
historically great
if they win it all this year
yeah they want 111 games this year their
run differential was something like plus
340. the Yankees led the American League
and it was way behind that differential
that the Dodgers had uh and they've been
such a good team even though they only
won the One World Championship in 2020
they've been a world championship
caliber team for so long so if you take
kind of this whole better part of a
decade under Dave Roberts if you look at
it that way they deserve consideration
as an all-time great team I brought this
up to a couple of guys who covered the
game uh see what your thought is if you
can have the career of Ken Griffey Jr or
Albert Pujols
foreign
you know like I'm kind of dodging it
you wouldn't want a baseball World
Without either one of them you know Ken
Griffey Jr became what he should have
become he was the one and only Ken
Griffey Jr and Pujols was the one and
only el hombre or the machine
um Griffey was the greater all-around
player because he was a spectacular
center fielder
Pujols has the greater statistics as a
hitter they're both obvious first ballot
Hall of Famers Griffey was near
unanimous that barrier has been broken
now by Rivera getting all the votes and
Jeter missing by only one so Pujols
might be unanimous in five years when
when he comes up
um I guess if you're just talking about
a kid's dreams I think a kid would dream
of playing center field like Willie Mays
or like Ken Griffey Jr more than he
would dream of being a first baseman or
a designated hitter which is not a knock
on pool halls so if you're talking about
a 10 year old kid who could be Ken
Griffey Jr or uh or Albert Pujols
probably more of those 10 year old kids
would would choose Griffey if you were
shohei otani's agent what would you do
I would wait for Artie Moreno to sell a
team and then walk in to the office of
whoever purchased it and said I'd like
you to meet shohei Otani your new
partner owner of your team and if you're
not good with that there are 29 other
teams that are very much interested have
a nice day
can I pay him for playing two positions
like it can is could he be a 60 million
dollar player if I give him 40 as a
hitter and 20 is a pitcher or split at
30 30. I mean he's he can be an All-Star
either but can he command two salaries
not quite but he can command more than
what a single Superstar's salary would
command for either being an All-Star
hitter or a Cy Young contending pitcher
plus you got to factor in the gate
attraction uh and his value uh to a
multicultural fan base as well
um and his commercial value Beyond
whatever his one team is he has
tremendous commercial value to the sport
you can't compare anyone to Michael
Jordan but Michael Jordan had value to
the NBA obviously beyond the Chicago
Bulls
shoheiotani is not at that level no
baseball player even Aaron judge this
year is at that level it's harder to get
the superstars of the game onto the
biggest stages in baseball has witness
the fact that Ken Griffey Jr who we just
mentioned never played in a World Series
so I'm not comparing Otani to Jordan at
that level but it's the same kind of
idea there's a handful of baseball
players who are really important to the
sport overall not just to their teams
autonomy is one judge is another
I'll leave you with this we embrace the
almost uh mythology behind Bo Jackson
but we don't do that with Dion Sanders
why is that
well because what Beau did uh in
baseball
I think was easier to grasp you look at
Bose highlights in baseball not that
there were that many of them but enough
to remember 500 foot home runs scaling
the wall like Spider-Man the throw that
got Harold Reynolds at the plate and
Harold still can't believe that he was
somehow thrown out on that play he just
seemed to be if he had fulfilled his
potential he seemed to have been capable
of being a Hall of Famer in both
football and baseball I don't think
anyone ever said that Deion Sanders was
likely to be a Baseball Hall of Famer
yeah I feel that way but it's almost
like Bo's Legend has grown
just and and I you know I remember
experiencing it and watching him in
football and baseball and it felt like
he could have been an All-Star maybe a
Hall of Famer in either one of those but
but he wasn't whereas Dion is a Hall of
Famer in football and you know had a
pretty solid baseball career oh yeah he
would have been if he just played
baseball a very good baseball player
likely would have been an All-Star some
Seasons he's arguably the greatest
defensive back ever certainly on the
short list there but there was something
about Beau that just seemed bigger and
you know what might have been is always
a compelling narrative not just in
sports but outside Sports uh the person
whose career or even in some cases life
is cut short there's an element that
adds to the mythology so Bo has that
going for him and luckily he's still
drawing breath so he didn't have to take
the second route
yeah this happens with you know
musicians or artists when when they die
early sure um uh what do 62 home runs
mean to you
I think it means what it means to most
reasonable fair-minded Baseball fans
it feels legitimate it feels authentic
we can speak euphemistically and say
it's the Yankee record it's the American
League record but it's the record for
all of baseball history outside of the
late 90s and early 2000s from 98 to 2000
in Four Seasons three guys combined to
have six seasons of more than 62 home
runs whereas in the entire history of
the game apart from that now more than a
century since the Advent of the Lively
ball three guys have done it and barely
so at 60 61 and 62. and as I said on the
broadcast last night not taking pot
shots at anyone else there's no need to
demonize Barry Bonds I want his natural
merits was one of the greatest players
who ever played in any era Mark McGuire
is a good guy Sammy Sosa brought joy to
Wrigleyville that isn't the point but if
you look at the home runs per time at
bat judge Ruth Maris are roughly in the
same range of a home run once every 9 9
to 10 times at bat if you look at
McGuire and bonds not so much Sosa but
Maguire and bonds they distorted those
figures to the point where it became a
video game and when people try to
compare them to other Generations well
Ruth played against a segregated
competition yes that's true but what
does any of this have to do with Babe
Ruth Hank Aaron held the career record
Roger Maris who played in the 50s and
60s held the single season record the
real tell is to compare any of those
guys to themselves because all three of
them had established lengthy statistical
histories before they began taking
steroids and other Peds and they
exceeded their already established past
levels not by small amounts but
exponentially and that tells you all you
need to know it doesn't mean they're bad
guys it does mean that what they did
goes into a different category in the
minds of most reasonable well-informed
people great to talk to you as always
and uh Bob will be on the call game two
tomorrow with Ron Darling on uh TBS
thank you Bob thanks a lot Dan okay take
care all right now that'll be at 7 30
Eastern TBS the exclusive home of the
ALDS and Al Sears